before we start today have you checked
out our new channel visual academy
if you haven't you should definitely do
it now the link is in the description
6 bc he was the son of olympus it covers
all the most interesting places
people and periods in history from
genghis khan to the ancient greeks or
my personal favorite the vikings with
fantastic animation and incredible
storytelling
and some voiceovers from people you
might recognize check out visual academy
here on youtube
and let us know what you think and now
let's get started
[Music]
so my friends on the 2nd december 2020
legislative elections were held in
venezuela well rather than the elections
what was celebrated was a pantomime a
parody
a con a great swindle in which the
supposedly official party the psuv the
party led by nicholas maduro
reaped the absolute majority in the
national assembly which is
the venezuelan parliament a majority
that has less value than a lottery
ticket filled in
after the draw when the winning numbers
are already known and no
i'm not exaggerating because my friends
this is not a matter of left
or right in fact not even the socialist
international believes the intentions of
the bolivarian regime anymore
check this out the socialist
international called the elections by
the maduro regime
illegitimate infobae the socialist
international once again
raises its voice to express its resolute
support and solidarity with the people
of venezuela and with their democratic
forces who have again
seen their liberties and rights
seriously violated by the dictatorial
regime of nicolas maduro
on this occasion with the illegitimate
legislative elections held yesterday
communique of the socialist
international on december 7th 2020. if
there is one thing that stands out about
this process it was precisely that of
the enormous abstention that was
registered according to the ball of iron
national electoral council only a little
more than
30 percent of venezuelans with the right
to vote actually did so a voter turnout
figure that the observatory against
fraud a body created by the parliament
itself
reduced to around 20 and that the
democratic unity roundtable placed at
just over
15 of the census in other words nicholas
maduro's party won an absolute majority
in parliament with the support of only
11 to 20
of venezuelans who are eligible to vote
and that's without taking into account
all the rigging and shenanigans that
were carried out do you want some
concrete examples
if you do listen up
[Music]
practically all of the opposition the
real opposition did not make an
appearance and yet
many parties at least eight of them
including juan guedos were intercepted
by the bolivarian justice system which
put at the head of the parties people
who may consider it appropriate
yeah that's right between 2019 and 2020
the maduro courts deposed opposition
party leaders to replace them with
people who wear
let's just say more suitable for the
regime
and of course that's not all the
composition of the electoral body was
irregularly elected by maduro's
government it was determined that in
some constituencies they would literally
vote by a show of hands
the composition of the assembly was
altered to favor small districts
perfectly controlled by the regime
and it's best that we don't mention the
recounts the list of irregularities
was long very long
precisely because of this no country or
moderately serious international body
has recognized the elections
as such but hold on a minute because
surprisingly we can still find cases
like that of the former spanish
president jose luis rodriguez zapaterro
who not only attended as an electoral
observer
and considered the elections legitimate
but even grumbled that the opposition
had not wanted to participate
in this rigged event
[Music]
in any case beyond the opinion that some
may have about the reasons that led
zapaterro to defend or white watch
nicholas maduro's regime
in today's visual politics video we want
to answer a clear and concise question
how does bolivar and democracy
really work in other words can we really
refer to venezuela as a democracy how
does the government of nicolas maduro
manage to stay in power you see my
friends what you're about to see is a
story of
exploitation abuse looting and
destruction
are you ready if so let's get cracking
[Music]
the fictitious democracy
so friends those of you who regularly
follow visualpolitik will know that we
have talked a lot
about venezuela and the truth is that
although at times it seems that the
country has disappeared from the big
headlines these days things over there
are as bad as ever which for at least
two decades in venezuelan terms means
they're even worse
than ever but as we have already told
you in this video we are going to try
and focus on how the rule of law and
bolivarian democracy
really works or to put it another way
how chavez-ism has turned democracy
into a more decorative world and no this
is not an unfounded accusation or an
unwarranted denunciation
[Music]
we only have to review the reports of
among others the inter-american
commission on human rights
human rights watch the organization of
american states or
the office of the united nations high
commissioner for human rights a body led
by michelle bachelet
a former president of chile and a person
who in her political life was not
exactly hostile to the chavez revolution
at least
i don't think anyone can credibly accuse
her of being a pawn of the international
right or
a puppet of the miami madrid washington
access to which the dictator nicolas
maduro
so often refers and yes i said dictator
because the results of all these human
rights reports make it clear that the
only person who really continues to
believe that venezuela is a more or less
functional democracy
is unfortunately the former president of
the spanish government jose louise
rodriguez zapatero but
let's get to the point let's go deeper
into the political and social reality of
this country
what exactly do these reports say about
human rights well
let's start with the un report
[Music]
the report of the un high commissioner
for human rights was published in 2019.
it took into account all of the data
collected during several visits by u.n
officials between september 2018
and march 2019. and while it is true
that maduro's regime facilitated
at least to all appearances the work of
these observers in several detention
centers and even allowed un evaluators
to speak with several detainees the
truth is that not even that softened the
conclusions of these experts about what
is happening today
in venezuela
because my friends the words were harsh
very harsh special denounces torture and
executions in the maduro government el
pai
complaints that of course still persist
to this day more than a year after the
report was published because this is how
the bolivarian regime works it is the
reality that nobody wants nor
can hide anymore 25th of september 2020
bachelet denounces more than 2
000 extra judicial executions in
venezuela in 2020 abc and that
is not an isolated complaint venezuela
extrajudicial executions
in low-income areas a pattern of serious
police abuse that goes unpunished
human rights watch 2nd of december 2020
the oas denounces more than 18
000 extrajudicial executions in
venezuela and questions the role of the
icc
europa press that last report by the way
has only just been released it is an
update and extension of the 2018 report
and what do you want me to say the
figures that the organization of
american states has now put on the table
are simply terrifying according to the
oas
nicolas maduro is responsible for more
than 18 000 extrajudicial executions
more than 15 500 cases of arbitrary
detention and imprisonment 724 cases of
forced disappearance between 2018 and
2019 alone
and hundreds and hundreds of documented
cases of torture including sexual
violence and all of this without
counting the climate of enormous
violence and misery that the regime has
created in the streets
our report brings to life the
extraordinary suffering of the people of
venezuela
inflicted by nicholas maduro and his
regime the only reasonable conclusion to
be drawn
from examining the scale and extent of
human rights abuses
such as extrajudicial executions
arbitrary detentions and the imposition
of living conditions designed to cause
great suffering or death is that these
actions constitute crimes against
humanity
jared genzer oas special advisor friends
we're talking repression information
censorship political censorship
persecution of dissidents economic
crisis paramilitary groups roaming at
large
torture a health crisis lack of food and
medicine and the list
just goes on the reports from each and
every one of these organizations make
official everything we already knew
about venezuela but that only came to us
through the media or through the
testimonies of the venezuelans
themselves
in this way the united nations has
formally verified the regular practice
of
torture in detention centers by means of
electrocutions asphyxiation with plastic
bags deprivation of water and food
beatings and countless other aggressions
all of this was carried out by officials
from seven the venezuelan intelligence
service the ball of iron national guard
or the directorate general of military
counterintelligence
and then we have the faes the phase the
venezuelan special action forces which
are accused of creating
real death squads squads that approach
their targets in unidentified vans
sometimes without license plates
and once there they break into the homes
of supposed opponents or people who are
uncomfortable with the regime without
any kind of core order they often do so
dressed in black
and wearing balaclavas they steal loot
and arrest as
many people as they want in fact this
type of operation
usually contributes to the list of
violent deaths classified as
resistance to authority which adds up as
we have seen to more than eighteen
thousand cases in the last five years
alone and it's not just the government
bodies the official ones
not at all
the ball of iron regime has also created
military or rather paramilitary
intelligence and defense units using
civilians through local structures such
as the communal councils the units of
battle hugo chavez and the network of
socio-political articulation and action
the raas
we're talking about structures that in
practice function as parallel units to
the state but that are directly at its
service or rather by the service of the
government their members can do almost
any savage act to maintain the regime
without the need to wear
any uniform and of course as you can
imagine
all of these groups official or not act
with total impunity among other things
because the courts of justice and
judicial bodies are directly controlled
by the government
and the psuv the united socialist party
of venezuela the all-powerful party the
party of nicolas maduro and other
bolivarian satraps
so the courts tend not to preside over
they dismiss or even cover up cases of
police abuse summary executions or
repression by the different groups that
make up the bolivarian action network
and then
as if that were not enough we then have
to add to all this the intervention and
control of the media and the
instrumentalization
of even the supposed social programmes
for example the venezuelan government
has a food distribution program through
local committees for supply and
production which distribute the
so-called clap boxes which are part of a
kind of social assistance policy
implemented by maduro well
to access these food boxes you have to
sign up and the government has to
include you on their distribution list
and of course receiving items depends on
how close to the government you are
because this process can be more or less
fast or even reversible depending on
citizens actions this is because the
list of beneficiaries of social
programmes is basically managed by local
structures of the ruling psuv party that
is if you want to receive this aid you
must remain silent
and be very careful not to speak out
against the government and also
don't forget the difficult economic
situation venezuela is going through
just think that we are talking about a
country where the united nations found
that many people can barely eat once a
day more than 4.5 million venezuelans
already suffer from malnutrition so
not having access to these programs
however miserable they may be
can be a huge problem
blackmail did someone say blackmail
friends none of this is speculation not
even the denunciation of opposition
groups all of these issues have been
confirmed by an infinite number of
international bodies the maduro regime
has extended its control over all
aspects of venezuelan society it has
dismantled democratic institutions and
has repressed by force
any real political dissidence
as we have seen to achieve its
objectives the regime has not hesitated
to attack journalists to violently
disarm demonstrators and to imprison
torture make disappear or kill thousands
of opponents and then
to top it off they have a terrible
crisis the real economic collapse that
the country is experiencing
poverty is on the rise hyperinflation is
uncontrollable and there is a huge
shortage of commodities including health
and pharmaceutical products to give you
an idea of the scale of the disaster in
october 2020 it was estimated that more
than five and a half million people had
left the country in recent years
more than five and a half million people
to give you an idea we are already
talking about one of the largest
displaced population in the world
more than that caused by many wars in
real terms the gdp per capita has shrunk
to the level at hand in the 1940s
obviously my friends given such
conditions you can guess what kind of
democracy is in the country because no
democracy is not only about voting in
fact that is almost
the least of it a democratic system
needs plurality freedom of expression
freedom of the press
an effective rule of law justice freedom
to demonstrate transparency and
an independent electoral commission and
in the bolivarian regime
there is nothing like that because
nicolas maduro's regime is simply a
[Music]
dictatorship
a cruel dictatorship that has destroyed
the lives of millions of people and
annihilated the lives of thousands and
thousands of venezuelans because they
were considered
unsuitable it is incomprehensible that
there are still people
including as we said before an
ex-president of the spanish government
who served spurious interests and who
continue to support
defend or justify the bolivarian regime
[Music]
you see my friends what was experienced
on sunday the 6th of december 2020. no
matter how much jose luis rodriguez
zapatero insists on saying otherwise
was not a democratic election but a vile
ruse the umpteenth attempt by the
venezuelan regime to camouflage what
they really are
a cruel dictatorship but having reached
this point
it's your turn the situation in
venezuela is terrible but finding a
solution seems increasingly complicated
that is why i'm asking you directly what
do you think would have to happen
in venezuela for things to change how
could the regime of nicolas maduro be
overthrown without inflicting even more
damage to the venezuelan people and how
safe is the democracy
in your country leave your answers in
the comments below so as always we
really hope you enjoyed this video
please hit like if you did and don't
forget to subscribe for brand new videos
also don't forget to check out our
friends at the reconsider media podcast
they provided the vocals in this episode
that weren't my dulcet tones finally
this channel is possible because of
patreon and our patrons on that platform
please consider joining them and
supporting our mission of providing
independent political coverage and
as always i'll see you next time and if
you want to learn more about politics
and hear
even more of my lovely voice you can
join us at
reconsider media we have a podcast at
reconsider media.com
podcast see you there